Donald Trump ran a clinic online with
statistics regarding the NFL nonsense
and I thought that this would be a
really interesting thing to go through
I've been doing this as some of you know
I'm teaching as an adjunct professor at
Boston College and we've had a number of
class sessions on media literacy we've
talked about lying with statistics we've
talked about basic critical thinking
skills and there's lots of really great
examples of how one can lie with
statistics and manipulate data in really
any number of ways including visually
including other ways so here's just a
couple of examples and then we'll get
into what Donald Trump did right so
imagine this statement our graduating
class earns an average of eighty five
thousand dollars per year within five
years of graduation now let's keep that
up because there's a few ways that this
can be incredibly deceptive number one
is there a built-in bias here in other
words was responding mandatory or are
you more likely to respond to a survey
asking about your income if your income
is better if you graduated from whatever
school is touting this statistic and
you're only making $22,000 a year are
you even going to respond so is there a
built-in bias another key point here is
the use of the word average an average
of eighty five thousand dollars a year
average could be the median average
could be the mean and average could be
the mode in this particular case median
would really be the most representative
of how the overall graduating class is
doing your mean could be heavily
upwardly skewed by a couple of people
making a ton of money it wouldn't really
represent what most people are making
and then you also have correlation
versus causation our graduating class
earns an average of eighty-five thousand
dollars per year within five years of
graduation
are they earning that because they
graduated from your school or are the
people that get accepted to your school
whether they go or not already more
likely to earn more money because they
are of a certain you know academic
caliber that would get them accepted in
the first place in other words it would
be interesting to compare
how much are people making who were
accepted to the school but didn't go
right so correlation versus causation
here's another way that you can lie with
statistics truncating the y-axis of
graphs lots of really good examples of
this here's a fox news graph of the
change in the cost of gas and I think
this was from the time when a President
Obama became president and they wanted
to sort of make it appear as though gas
prices were way up under Obama by only
showing you a chart that has a sort of
as its upper and lower limits two
dollars and ninety cents per gallon and
three dollars and sixty cents per gallon
the uptick of 30-something cents in gas
per gallon seems really big even though
it's only a small increase this is
truncating the y-axis of a graph even
the x-axis on this one I mean look at
you got last year and then last one week
and in current and then what about it
yeah that also doesn't make any sense
another example of truncating the y-axis
if the Bush tax cuts expire right this
is during President Obama's presidency
what will happen if the Bush tax cuts
expire you see on the Left that's a very
very low amount and on the right Wow
look at that big bar chart and it looks
like it went way up well the entire
graph only shows you from 34 to 42
percent and you're talking about a 4.6
percentage point increase and one more
example of lying by truncating that this
one is just a mess this is job loss by
quarter and if you look at this one and
I'll describe it to the audience that's
listening you have an uneven y-axis and
a totally bogus x-axis you have a
different amount of time between each of
the points on this graph and you have
different amounts of jobs and it's just
a straight line I mean this one's so
crazy Pat that it's hard to even dig
into what's wrong with it without
spending an hour on it
okay so background many ways to live
with statistics this now gets us to
Donald Trump there is another way to lie
with statistics which is called ignoring
the base rate I'm gonna give you an
example of ignoring the base rate if I
tell you crime is up five percent in New
York City
that means policing in New York
city is a disaster compared to no change
in crime crime being up 5% is bad but
what if I told you that the nationwide
crime rate was up 20%
well if nationwide crime is up 20% and
in New York City it's only up 5% that
actually means New York City is doing
pretty well in terms of change to crime
right that is called the base rate
Donald Trump went on Twitter and he
started trying to Pat himself on the
back saying that as a result of the
criticism of his you know his sons of
[ __ ] in the NFL comment that people
immediately started boycotting the NFL
and that ratings are way down so Donald
Trump said on Twitter quote if NFL fans
refused to go to games until players
stop disrespecting our flag and country
you will see change take place fast fire
or suspend Donald Trump also on Twitter
NFL attendance and ratings are way down
boring games yes but many stay away
because they love our country League
should back the United States and lastly
Trump on Twitter great solidarity for
our national anthem and for our country
standing with locked arms is good
kneeling is not acceptable bad ratings
so the implication here is because
people are not happy with the kneeling
during the anthem because of what Donald
Trump has been pointing out the bad
ratings are happening Trump is
responsible for telling people don't
watch the NFL boycott the NFL now it is
true compared to prior year's NFL
ratings are down and part of it might be
there's just more competition there's
more things to watch part of it might be
people who are getting more accustomed
to not watching stuff live because of on
demand TV part of it could be the
concussion crisis right making people
less interested in football there's lots
of systemic things going on but this
particular Sunday as well as Monday
Night Football ratings were actually up
ESPN sports business reporter Darren
Revell was on Twitter and he said
preliminary ratings for NFL games on CBS
yesterday were up four percent versus
week three of
last year its pregame show had the
highest viewership in seven years then
you have John or rond a media reporter
for the sports Business Journal on
Twitter overnights from Fox and CBS
pregame shows were up 19% yesterday
combined also mentioning overnights from
Sunday's game are down around 4% on Fox
CBS and NBC combined week three likely
to be up once and Monday night football
gets factored in so Donald Trump is it's
really a textbook example of lying with
statistics Trump is talking about
statistic more broadly and over time
being down for the NFL he might be lying
he might just be distorting on purpose
we don't really know but many sports
have ratings that are down specifically
after this kneeling crisis though the
NFL actually had higher ratings Trump is
ignoring the base rate which is
background of lower ratings higher
ratings this past Sunday and the other
thing that Trump and maybe Fox News will
do is just omit information so a new
jobs report will come out and it will
say that the economy added 200,000 jobs
and then unemployment ticked down to
four point three percent sure well scale
that back a little bit it's just
continuing the trend that we saw under
Barack Obama it's not like Trump came in
with bad jobs numbers and turned the
whole thing around and and not only that
also these are very similar jobs numbers
that under President Obama were both not
good and fake even though they all came
from the Bureau of Labor Statistics so
yeah there are endless examples of this
and if this type of stuff is interesting
to you I'm sort of thinking about taking
the long the 75 minute lectures that I'm
doing in the class I'm teaching at
Boston College where we talk about a lot
of this stuff and turning them into
maybe like YouTube lectures hour and 15
minute YouTube lectures with the slides
that I use and talking through a lot of
this stuff I when I mentioned it on a
live stream not long ago a bunch of
people seemed really interested in it
but this is it's a major project right
like we're producing an hour a day five
day a week national show and we're doing
a whole bunch of other stuff and doing
YouTube live streams taking these
lectures and slides and making seventy
five minute videos it's a major major
project so I would love for it to work
but I don't know yet how we'll do it
well we already have those deeper
which were maybe 20 minutes long if we
had an hour plus long content for would
be a deepest dive it's it would be the
deepest dives ever folks believe me I
would have never seen a deeper dive than
when we do the online lecture so if it
is interesting to look at doing
something like that let me know more
interestingly if maybe you would want to
help out and participate in making that
happen that would actually be the most
interesting thing because our resources
here are stretched pretty thin so get in
touch a lot more of this media literacy
critical thinking stuff is available and
you can of course discuss any of these
stories with us on our reddit discussion
forum david pakman.com slash our IDI di
t we'll take a break and be back with
more right after this